kidnapped man has been found nearly 30
years after disappearing Omar bin omran
disappeared age 19 bin Oman told his
Rescuers he could some sometimes see his
family from afar but that he felt
incapable of calling out of the spell
his cap has cast
upon just imagine the people back in the
day when they would have to travel
certain distances for months or even
years what is one thing that they would
carry with them the Quran why because
they did not have it on their mobile
devices or their gadgets brothers and
sisters imagine you have a app the Quran
app which not only shows you how much
rewards you get but reminds you to read
the Quran gives you reminders download
the Quran app now and let it testify for
you on your that you read it wherever
you was the video we're about to see is
of a man who disappeared for 26 years
and what you're going to hear is
horrifying because he was just 200 M
away just imagine you have a neighbor
200 M away
and your sibling your loved one who's
missing for 26 years is in that basement
here is the clip and here is the
chilling message and description Subhan
Allah which the investigation has shown
who was the one who kidnapped him what
was holding him back and the man claims
it was and this is why we belittle these
issues the Unseen World and I'm going to
come to how we can protect ourself here
was the video kidnapped man has been
found nearly 30 years after disappearing
Omar bin omran disappeared aged 19 while
on the way to school and was discovered
in a neighbor's sheep pen 26 years later
now 45 years old in a blurry video
broadcasted on Algerian TV a search
party shines torches into a pit
surrounded by hay where Omar stares up
seemingly in shock while Omar's family
thought he had died in the Algerian
Civil War the neighbor aged 61 is now in
police custody it's also reported that
relatives say their dog was poisoned
after it began smelling Omar's scent
close by Subhan Allah when we talk about
black magic and people belittle it
people don't really believe in it we
don't really believe in the Unseen World
and this is why I always tell people
make sure your Salah is on point like we
did a reac video about the Russian
magician who said that she couldn't
attack the Muslims cuz they had a
protective Dome why because they pra
Salah the extra protection on top of
protection is what your morning and
evening of black magic evil eye evil
people who want to do evil jealousy Envy
so many things that we need to be
protected from now hear the story an
alerian man who went missing in 1998
during the country Civil War has been
found alive in his NE neighbor's Cellar
26 years later according to authorities
but listen to this it's very profound
and it goes to YF Alam Story the
country's Ministry of Justice said on
Tuesday that the man identified
alternatively as Omar bin Oman or Omar B
disappeared when he was 19 years old and
was long assumed have been K kidnapped
or killed but he was found alive earlier
this week at the age of 45 after being
held captive by a neighbor in a
Sheepfold hidden by Hast stack just 200
M from his old home in zelfa part of
North Algeria the ministry said that an
investigation to the heinous crime was
ongoing and that the victim is receiving
medical and psychological care now
listen very carefully police detained
the alleged captor a 61-year-old Dorman
after he attempted to flee the
kidnapping was discovered after the
suspect's brother posted a revealing
information on a social media on social
media amid an Alle inheritance dispute
between the siblings look at this on
12th May at 8:00 p.m. local time they
found the victim Omar bin Oman age 45 in
the cell of his neighbor ba age 61 a
court official said the victim's mother
died in 2013 when his family still
believed he was likely to be dead media
outlets in Algeria reported that bin
omran told his Rescuers he could
sometimes see his family from afar but
that he felt incapable of calling out of
the spell cap has cast upon him being
oman's discovery on Sunday solves a
mystery that he had lingered he had
lingered in his community since
algeria's bloodly Civil War relatives of
the war victims are still Seeking
Justice now guys this is very
interesting Subhan Allah yeah okay why
because just imagine you can see your
family members you can shout out to them
you're 200 M away what is stopping you a
full capable grown man 19 uh year old
for 26 years has he could have let me
tell you something Al Chapo what's his
name this guy who's a drug lord Etc
managed to es scrape the most high uh uh
guarded prison how does an individual
not be able to you see when magic these
things hit you when you don't do your
and protection forget doing your Salah
you don't forget doing you don't even
pray your Salah guys Subhan Allah
brothers and sisters this is why I so so
focused on Salah this is what does and
it was done to the prophet peace be upon
him the prophet on him was done towards
him by a Jewish person they grabbed a
string of his a piece of his hair on a
comb and even there was Nots that was
tied that's why andas was sent and the
prophet peace upon him was under
assumption that he he became a bit
deluded thinking he did things that he
did not do and this only happens with
the permission of Allah subhana wa tala
by the way this shows us the prophet is
the best fine example it shows that if
it can happen to him and Allah sent a
cure and Allah cured him alhamdulillah
and it never affected revelation any way
shape or form what do you think me and
you are prone to this man it's the that
stops him and believe me brothers and
sisters I've had personal experience in
my life when I went through something
similar I'm not going to say I was
bewish Etc or black magic whatever but
there were certain things that I
couldn't do that I can usually do
brothers and sisters this is why I do
not miss my morning and evening you have
to make sure the Unseen World Is Real if
I told you the mafia's after you you
will change your location you'll change
your house you get security you have
bulletproof vest you will do all kinds
of stuff the Jin and the and the human
with the black magic and that can only
be done with the permission of Allah by
the way yes it is more dangerous than a
mafia who wants to kill you so brothers
and sisters when it comes to this stuff
do your morning and evening pray your
Salah abstain from major sins abstain
from sins because these ways these
things are a Gateway for the jins and S
to affect you Allah has given you the
Cure brothers and sisters I urge you
guys to protect yourself inshallah and
you can see even with the issues of
inheritance maybe this man was kidnapped
by his family members because of
inheritance and they were told do you
not kill him like y Alam one of his
brothers came and said no don't kill him
rather get rid of him and he was hidden
because of few pounds we don't know but
may Allah subhana wa tala protect us and
please take this matter very seriously
Subhan Allah it's fine evidence that is
real it is H and the prophet has warned
us against it inshallah so brothers and
sisters inshallah like I said before it
is only with the permission of Allah
subhana wa tala if this inflicted you it
is by the permiss of Allah and it is
like Allah says you might hate something
which is good for you you might love
something which is bad for you submit to
it and ask Allah rid you and cure you
from it inshallah and before that though
make sure you do your your Salah and St
inform ma till next time